[Musique]
et bien un bonsoir à tous je tiens à
vous rassurer sur ma santé mentale je ne
suis pas atteint du syndrome de diogène
ce qui me vaut d'être là ce soir je vous
donne un petit indice
on a annoncé le sujet c'est qu'en fait
je suis la conjonction entre un
photographe d'une part et un très
mauvais cuisine et d'autre part
d'ailleurs pour avoir entendu
l'intervention précédente
j'aurais dû prendre un peu plus 100 de
ma microbiote il se trouve que j'ai
dumas survie alimentaire à la
consommation de plats préparés d'une
célèbre marque de plats surgelés
français dont la décence m'interdit
mogis pardon à taire le nom
j'en ai fait la base de mon alimentation
pendant presque 10 de 10 ans et 1 jour
bêtement j'ai juste oublié de sortir ma
poubelle
ce jour là je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais générer une quantité de déchets
astronomiques
j'ai commencé un peu à me pencher sur la
question et je me suis dit que je me
sens j'ai réalisé que ces déchets il
avait un coût qui était double il avait
un coup au moment il était question
d'acheter un produit mais il y en avait
un deuxième parce qu'il fallait bien le
jeter le faire collecter et le faire
recycler dès lors je me suis dit je me
suis penché sur la question et je me
suis dit je vais faire je vais relever
un défi je vais en faire une série
photographique et à partir de ce jour je
n'ai plus jeter aucun de mes déchets
recyclables pendant quatre ans alors je
tiens à préciser que j'ai été aidé parce
qu'en fait je ne consomme pas tous les
produits donc il ya 200 amis et
collègues qui m'ont prêté main forte et
qui m'ont aidé à compléter ma d'échec
en france il est vrai plupart des pays
occidentaux aujourd'hui toutes les
semaines les déchets disparaître de
notre vie toutes les semaines ils sont
collectés et c'est pas nous qui avons à
gérer justement cette quantité
astronomique
quand on se penche sur les chiffres et
la plupart dans la plupart des cas les
déchets sont abordés sous forme de
chiffres ici une source de l'ademe en
2014 on ajouté 324 millions de tonnes de
déchets c'est inconcevable on peut le
transférer ou à trouver une
correspondance avec des terrains de foot
le transformer en nombre de tour eiffel
c'est quelque chose qui va rester
abstrait je me suis dit que justement la
force de la photo c'était de mettre une
image sur cette problématique est donc
le fruit de ma collec tu m'as permet
d'acquérir entre guillemets 70 mètres
cubes de déchets vous voyez sur cette
image c'est 30 % de ce que j'ai
accumulée chez moi c'est pas ça pas été
le fruit d'une commande
c'est à dire que personne ne m'a demandé
de travailler sur cette question c'est
un sujet que j'ai fait par conviction et
donc je me suis retrouvé à vivre pendant
quatre ans ce qui était pas l'idée
n'était pas de faire une performance
mais je me suis retrouvé à créer un
centre de tri chez moi donc j'ai retiré
70 mètres cubes clandestinement du
circuit du tri de la métropole lilloise
il faut savoir que ça ça c'est ma
cuisine et c'est une des pièces dans
lesquelles je me suis gardé le plus d
espace vital il faut imaginer un
appartement dans lequel tout était
dédiée au stockage
par exemple dans ma chambre j'avais 4800
rouleaux de papier toilette
j'avais cinq mille paquets de cigarettes
j'avais un bureau à l étage dont je n'ai
pas vu le bout pendant plusieurs années
le traitement que j'ai choisi de donner
à cette problématique il a été
particulier en fait j'ai choisi de
donner un traitement qui sont un petit
peu un traitement publicitaire de
déchets ça a quelque chose qui est plus
ragoûtants personne n'a envie de
vraiment de s'y intéresser et c'est un
peu plus tôt loin des yeux loin du coeur
le parti que j'ai pris dès le départ c
était d'isoler les déchets pour leur
donner justement une dimension qui soit
graphique si j'avais tout mélanger jouer
un rendu qui aurait été un petit peu
différent et je voulais justement
travaillé sur la dimension esthétique et
servir une image qui sont un petit peu
choquant
la proportion que je donne aux déchets
dont chacune des images que j'ai
produites est toujours beaucoup plus
impressionnante que la place du modèle
chaque image a été construite dans la
série parce que quand on fait une série
d images justement il faut créer du
rythme ça c'est une des images
d'introduction qui questionne le rapport
entre l'homme et son environnement
on voit bien qu'on a une structure en
béton en arrière qui représente la main
de l'homme sur la nature et au premier
plan de la végétation qui va nous
ramener rappelé plus tôt une forêt
primaire
l'idée c'est de créer du contraste les
modèles qui ont posé dans cette série
c'est donc pas des modèles
professionnels
ce sont des amis ce sont ma famille à
chaque fois j'ai dû les briser par
exemple la volonté que j'ai voulu
exprimer en tout cas au travers de mes
images
c'est de demander aux gens de faire
abstraction de cette réalité il ya
quelque chose est un petit peu gênant
dans l'image
quand on regarde bien finalement toute
alerte réalise et la personne fait
totalement abstraction de ce qui l
entoure
l'idée ce n'est pas de la m elle en
cause mais finalement de permettre au
lecteur de se projeter dans cette image
et de se poser la question de son propre
impact en termes de consommation et puis
ce que je veux ce que je voulais et apam
c'était culpabiliser le lecteur parce
que moi même je suis pas j'ai pas été un
exemple est justement une petite touche
ironique quand on regarde dans le détail
ce qu'elle tient dans les mains
la fête est retient la solution dans la
main en l'occurrence ici c'est une
orange
si elle avait choisi d'acheter des
oranges presse elle aurait plus eu prix
une grande partie des emballages qu'on
voit ici sur cette image je comprends
bien que l'alternative est difficile à
trouver et que c'est difficile de vivre
avec une vache dans sa cuisine comme
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
en fait moi j'ai pas consommer
l'ensemble de ses emballages
par exemple j'ai dû boire deux
bouteilles de lait en quatre ans ici je
vous laisse compter rapidement ici à
1600 bouteille de lait l'idée c'est de
servir justement un visuel qui soit
impactant si j'avais fait une photo avec
deux bouteilles de lait je serai chez
moi en train de regarder la télé c'est
ce qui marche d'ailleurs dans cette
série et elle m'a valu de gagner un prix
international et qui fait que le voyage
la série voyage aujourd'hui et il ya
beaucoup de gens à l'étranger qui se
retrouve finalement dans ces images
parce que elle avait été abordée sous
forme de statistiques
elle avait jamais été abordé avec cette
dimension là alors là ça m'a justement
parce que ça a été assez médiatisé et
justement on est une gastro entérologue
qui vient de passer juste juste avant
ici on a cinq mille 5000 rouleaux de
papier toilette
alors je vous rassure ce n'est pas le
fruit de ma propre consommation
je vais très bien
l'enjeu je pense aujourd'hui quand on
est photographe céder ses propos de
produire des images qui sont
interpellantes je pense que aujourd'hui
au quotidien on est submergé d'image
qu'on allume son ordinateur qu'on aille
sur le trajet du travail
on va voir des tonnes de publicité
l'enjeu je pense pour marquer les gens
c'est de produire un visuel qui les
interpellent et qui va sortir du lot en
général on représente assez peu les gens
sur leurs toilettes et j'imagine que
clotilde mon modèle se servira pas de
cette image pour son prochain cv
moi par par mes propres choix de
consommation et pour des contraintes qui
sont compréhensibles par ce que vous
imaginez bien que si j'ai choisi de
parler des déchets ménagers et des
emballages en particulier c'est parce
qu'ils avaient la faculté d'être
stockables j'ai pas pu aborder la
question des déchets organiques
parce que si c'est si vous avez gardé
aujourd'hui je serais allé tas de
terreau j'ai choisi aussi dans mes
images d'élargir un petit peu le propos
en fait ici on a le modèle qui
représentait dans une voiture est en
fait il ya une sorte de combos qui
marche plutôt bien entre la fumée tu
aurais pu être générés par la cigarette
mais ça questionne également notre
mobilité
parce que la fumée aurait pu être
générés par la voiture est en fait cette
problématique là parce que les déchets
c'est aussi une question autour de la
pollution elle et elle est questionné
ici et pour l'anecdote quand on a fait
l'installation en fait parmi ces cinq
mille paquets de cigarettes qu'on
m'avait donné le modèle en a trouvé un
qui était entier il était content
c'était légitime qu'ils le gardent
et donc on a fait le footing et pio à la
fin il était question de tout de tout
replié et de tout remettre de tout
ramener chez moi et il a perdu
il est retombé dans ses phases cinq
mille paquets de cigarettes
la moralité de l'histoire c'est quoi
bien mal acquis ne profite jamais
il faut savoir qu'il ya certaines des
images qu'on nécessitait 10 heures de
travail parce qu'en fait il fallait que
je prenne tout tout mon stock que
j'avais bien organisé par type chez moi
que j'aille faire la mise en scène parce
qu' il fallait justement recréer le
volume éclairé la scène shooter et puis
tout rapatrier à la maison en fait
j'aurais aimé aborder la question
beaucoup plus larges en tous cas
beaucoup plus largement
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est tout tous les
pans de notre façon de consommer qui
sont questionnés j'ai 38 ans j'aurais pu
mettre en scène le nombre de voitures
que j'ai eue le nombre de frigo que j'ai
utilisé le nombre de téléphones que
l'échangé le nombre de machines à laver
la problématique elle est beaucoup plus
large et le but dont tout cas le propos
que je tiens à développer c'est de se
dire que on est tous acteurs de cette
société mais les choix qu'on fait en
tant que consommateur il un ils ont un
lien ils ont une incidence pardon sur la
société et sur la consommation en
général
j'avais cet exemple du bio en disant qu'
il ya quelques années il épate de
d'offres en termes de bio et qu'elle
s'est développée avec le temps et c'est
vrai aujourd'hui dans votre supermarché
a minima il ya au moins un rayon bio ce
qui est intéressant et pour en avoir
discuté récemment c'est que c'est devenu
un modèle économique et ça a été
récupéré par les industriels et que
finalement aujourd'hui on peut acheter
un citron bio café vue mille kilomètres
et finalement est ce que c est ce que
c'est cohérent je pense pas je pense que
même la façon la façon donc choisi de
s'habiller
elle a aussi un impact sur
l'environnement pendant longtemps la
politique ça a été de dire on déplace le
problème on peut pas traiter en france
c'est pas grave on l'envoie en chine on
l'envoie en afrique sauf qu'aujourd'hui
les chinois ils sont dans une société
qui se développe et en fait ils filent
ils produisent eux mêmes une grande
quantité de déchets ils veulent plus
récupérer ce que ce que nous ont produit
des solutions qui existent et l'idée
c'est de vous dire qu'il faut moi même
je n'ai pas changé radicalement
je me suis mis à faire à manger et
j'essaye d'apporter ma petite pierre à
l'édifice c'est les petits ruisseaux qui
font les grandes rivières et même dans
la gestion des déchets en france et
encore beaucoup de chemin à parcourir
je pense à cette image j'ai beaucoup
donné dans cette image
cette photo elle un peu particulière
parce qu'elle représente principalement
des bouteilles des bouteilles en verres
et des bouteilles de bière alors pour
être lillois et pour vivre à proximité
de la belgique
on a on a en belgique ainsi fin ils ont
en belgique
un système qui s'appelle la consigne est
la consigne
le principe c'est de se dire qu'un
emballages vides il garde une valeur une
bouteille de verre en france on la casse
et on refait une bouteille il faut de
l'énergie pour refaire une bouteille en
belgique
ils vont la réutilisent ils vont laruns
et ils vont la réutiliser et pour
pouvoir le faire
ils ont standardisé les bouteilles ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui l'industrie
sans contrainte va vous vendre du
packaging
quand vous achetez des petites capsules
de café c'est beau à sa boîte pratique
mais vous payez 30 fois le prix du café
parce qu'en fait la valeur de l'argent
que vous dépensez c'est pour payer
l'emballage
quand on achète une belle boîte de
chocolats à noël qui brille qui est un
beau petit ruban en fait on n'offre pas
du chocolat on offre de l'emballage et
ça on le retrouve dans quand on regarde
un petit peu le contenu de nos poubelles
on va le retrouver dans plein d'autres
domaines on va regarder une autre image
ici il ya 800 kg de publicité en fait il
suffit de mettre un stop pub pour éviter
12 kg de papier par an et par personne
il suffit de faire des petites choses
simples et je pense que c'est difficile
d'attendre d'eux des gens de faire un
changement radical dans leur vie il faut
pas attendre que ce soit des politiques
publiques qui vous donnent la main pour
vous aider à faire mieux
à mon sens ce qui est important et ce
qui est le propos de moi de ma série
c'est vous dire que vous pouvez tous
être le levier de ce changement
en choisissant de consommer autrement
quand je pense par exemple au gaspillage
alimentaire aujourd'hui il ya la moitié
de la production alimentaire mondiale
qui finit dans une poubelle
pendant qu'une autre partie du monde qui
elle ne mange pas à sa faim
pourquoi parce qu'elle correspond pas
aux standards qu'on attend en fait il
suffit d'aller acheter ses légumes au
marché de faire travailler artisans du
coin et pour éviter justement de se
retrouver dans ce type de situation
parce que finasser succès sur des durées
très courtes que j'ai produit 7 cette
quantité de déchets et voilà le but de
mon travail c'est juste de vous rappeler
que le meilleur déchet c'est celui qu'on
ne produit pas merci
[Applaudissements]